She's given the name Nanase Kimito
, but to think she has that kind of power.
There are ways to make it possible,
such as a rumor that would normally take a long time to spread and reach a large number of people,
or an
accident that only makes up a small portion of the media coverage.
[Music] My
mother's is
just that kind of net.  It's also possible to do it
like that public figure riding site in one place Do you know? Then the
story is fast.
But, it's hard to convey just rumors, and you fixed it in no time Do
you remember that illustration
?  A
decent eyewitness testimony can be illustrated just like a ghost that is told only by pot rumors
Do you think it's possible?
Based on that illustration, there is no corporation, so it is materialized in that form
.
[Music]
Everything is the opposite.
You can say that this site is the true identity of Nanase Kojin.